[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the political journalist for the
financial times jasmine cameron chaleshi
and the scottish daily mail's deputy
political editor rachel watson so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now the metro suggests that the
omicron variant of covid may have peaked
in the uk as case numbers have fallen
for five days in a row
the chancellor is in favor of reducing
the self-isolation period from seven to
five days in a bid to ease staffing
shortages across the country
while the mirror has an investigation
into the conservatives levelling up
agenda reporting on a crumbling school
in yorkshire with no money for repairs
the mail pleads with the prime minister
save us from a cost of living crisis
boris
that's also the lead for the express
the guardian hears from campaigners who
insist the housing secretary michael
gove's four billion pound plan to
upgrade fireproof cladding on high-rise
buildings doesn't go far enough
the financial times quotes nato's
secretary-general jen stoltenberg
warning the organization is prepared for
a new armed conflict in europe if
negotiations with moscow fail and russia
invades ukraine
and we bet you think you think this
story is about you the star finds out
that modern men are vainer than women
my female director just said yep in my
ear
we're joined tonight by jasmine cameron
chalesi and rachel watson we're not
going to talk about that story let's go
up straight to the telegraph and rishi
sunaka throwing his weight behind uh
calls for a five-day isolation period
jasmine
yeah so it's quite interesting so first
we have the education secretary and now
we're hearing from the chancellor that
there are growing calls within the
government to reduce the isolation
period down to five days and it really
shows there is quite a bit of concern at
um the impact of covert linked staff
shortages on the economy it's not just
in hospitals in the nhs but it's also in
um you know training companies also
reporting it as well and i think we're
at this really interesting stage in a
pandemic where we we're hearing reports
of hundreds of thousands of cases but at
the same time we've got lots of people
getting their boost of vaccines we know
that we've got better treatments when it
comes to treating people with covert and
hospital and so it's only natural that
ministers are sort of assessing the
situation thinking what is a
proportionate response what do we need
to do now we're at this stage in
pandemic and how do we balance the
societal harms caused by code
restrictions alongside the health harms
caused by covert itself and so i think i
think the telegraph's reporting that
around 60 of those in cabinet are in
favor of cutting the self-isolation
period so i think it's probably
inevitable that we will see a change on
that front yes and that um
quote of the the 60 of cabinets being in
favor that also stressing that it would
have to be sanctioned as safe by
scientists before proceeding to that
rachel
yeah and i think this is another one of
those um areas that the conversations
start this weekend so around that and
cut self-isolation to five days that was
something that we heard as
we've just heard the education secretary
and the chancellor have put their back
in behind and but also that note of
caution around experts but again we
heard other kind of measures being
tested with the public this weekend such
as
the end to free lateral flow testing for
example now that seems like it's not
going to happen anytime soon but it
seems like the government is floating
this idea that that is where we are
headed in the pandemic now and you know
yes these case numbers that we have now
are very very high across the whole of
the united kingdom but we saw that in
scotland this week as well where the
first minister nicola sturgeon kind of
changed her tone a little bit and spoke
about how she would look to bring
forward a road map and framework to
dealing with the pandemic that wasn't
necessarily the way that's been dealt
with now and i think that seems to be
the point we're at where these measures
like can we cut self-isolation again
can we um do we need the testing at
levels that it's at the moment those
conversations just being floated at the
moment not necessarily that they're
going to happen this week or next week
but that that's where the government is
and that is where they want to get us to
the next couple of months and the metro
uh moving even further to suggesting
that uh omicron is on the the way out
with their headline going going crown
right uh jasmine
yeah so it's quite an optimistic splash
by the metro i think they've um cited
statistics that show daily cases are
falling for five days in a row which is
definitely encouraging but i think at
this point in the pandemic it's it's
slightly too early i think to say that
we've hit the peak um i'm always
cautious of looking at these daily
figures i think we need to look at sort
of weekly and monthly figures to get a
sense of the trends but i do think um
things are hopefully looking up the
metro sites and plan b and the vaccine
booster program is one of the causes of
that but i do think there is definitely
a concern about what's happening in
hospitals and the government's main one
of the government's main priorities
throughout the pandemic is making sure
the nhs is sort of you know doesn't keel
over and we've seen in the past few days
i think it's around
at least 20 hospitals have declared
critical incidents there's concern over
staff shortages and hospitals and and an
uptick in hospitalization so i think the
statistics are encouraging and i think
it's definitely not all doom and gloom
but i think we should still be quite
cautious in how we interpret these
figures yes rachel do you think this is
an irresponsible
headline because i mean it does suggest
that it's all over
i think there's been a real shift as i
said before this weekend and i think
when you're looking at case numbers
we're hearing people and experts talk
about how they think this is the peak
that we've reached the peak so it's
difficult for people not to feel
positive and have that sense of
positivity around it today we've heard
people talk about um the pandemic
reaching an endemic stage where we start
to learn to live with this
virus and one of the differences again
um
with this variant compared to others is
we've not seen those hospital numbers
reach
what they did in previous waves now
obviously there there is a caveat we're
not quite at that point that we might
expect numbers to peak there's still a
few weeks and particularly in scotland
we've been told you know it could be the
end of the month the month before we see
hospital numbers
peak but it is difficult although these
case numbers are very high and you know
previously um i would have thought we
would be in a complete lockdown with
numbers this high in scotland last week
we had one day where casey's hit 20
thousand in previous waves our um
highest number was seven thousand a day
so in previous uh waves of this virus
you might have expected to be in a full
and complete lockdown at this point but
we're not we're hearing from the
government um across the uk that they
are looking at ways to to move us
forward to live with this virus and so
you know this headline might be a little
bit positive i think you know maybe it
is um going a little bit um
they've got excited it is very positive
but it's difficult to kind of get that
get away from that sense when you have
people talking about
kind of moving out of restrictions and
and getting on with life and having this
virus is something to live with rather
than something that restricts that
restricts our daily lives
let's move on to reports of the cost of
living crisis and the mail urging the
prime minister to act senior tories
apparently warning him that unless he
tackles the cost of living crisis he
will be punished at the polls jasmine
yeah so i think there is a growing sense
of panic among conservative backbenchers
at the possible impact of this cost of
living crisis so we're expecting in
april the national insurance
contributions will go up we know that
energy bills are likely to go up as well
there are concerns about inflation and
there is a sense that um while johnson
has been criticized for his handling of
covert for example for um reports of
officials you know having parties during
lockdown there is a sense that
all of that sort of pales in comparison
to what will happen if people are
getting to the end of the month and
realizing that their pockets are being
squeezed realizing that their bills are
going up and actually that there will be
a political impact if voters feel as
though their lives have essentially got
worse
under a conservative government and
tory mps are very conscious of that and
they're urging johnson to essentially
reassure the public to put some measures
in place that will effectively mean that
people aren't seeing their their
paycheck squeezed
and rachel one senior conservative uh
saying that you know people being upset
about the ferrari over the number 10
parties will pass but what won't pass is
the anger people will feel when far from
being leveled up they find their
standard of living has been leveled down
yes and this is what will be
concerning those toy back ventures the
most with this is that just a few months
away we have the local council election
so this could be a very quick test of
how the public feel about this it's only
a few months away we'll see people go to
the polls and there's an interesting
quote in there from another
the chairman of the education committee
where he talks about this being the
number one issue facing the prime
minister at the moment which i do think
is the case i think the cost of living
people are going to see this in their
pockets people are concerned about their
energy prices they're concerned about
tax rises inflation and then the quote
continues there to say people voted for
boris johnson because they believed
their financial security and prosperity
would be better he has got to make it
happen and i think that's one of the
things with boris johnson he came into
government making a number of promises
people people believed people that voted
for him believed that he would make
their lives better whether that was
through brexit for business or that
people would see um their standards of
living better under his leadership and
if that doesn't happen if people feel
that they're
they're worse off under him if people
feel that they are not getting to where
they wanted to be that's a real concern
for conservatives and i think they will
be looking around and saying why isn't
the government acting what are you going
to do and you need to put measures in
place to ensure that people are not
getting to the end of the month that and
having to make really tough decisions on
how they spend their money
yes and that store is also on the front
of the express pms act now on cost of
living squeeze for the moment rachel and
jasmine thank you very much we are going
to take a break coming up a sky news
poll suggests a third of tories think he
should resign so is the writing on the
wall for boris johnson we'll discuss
that next
[Music]
you're watching the press preview still
with me jasmine cameron chelasi and
rachel watson let's take a look at the
metro and this is actually reporting on
a sky news story it's a yougov poll done
for us saying that one in three tories
say the prime minister should resign are
you shocked by that jasmine
um i mean it's not massively surprising
the past few weeks and months have seen
a flurry of negative headlines for
johnson we've seen his own back ventures
rebel against him there's been concern
about um you know
knock down breaking parties in downing
street there was the everything that
happened with the sleeve scandal so it
has been a bruising couple of months for
johnson and i do think there's a growing
sense that his political capital is
slowly running out here's someone who
came into power promising to get brexit
done promising to level up the country
and instead has had to spend the
majority of his premiership dealing with
a pandemic and so as a result has had to
spend billions has had to break
manifested promises has had to hike up
taxes and so even among back benches
there is a growing sense of unease about
what johnson stands for and how
conservativism is shaping up under his
leadership but i mean i think the poll
still suggests that the majority of um
support the majority still support
johnson even though it's quite a damning
statistic that one third when i get rid
of him but i do think it's natural at
this point you know he's a mid-term
leader it's natural that people are
looking around and thinking about
alternatives but i don't think he's
going anywhere anytime soon although i'm
sure there are many within his party who
are secretly tossing and planning um to
find her successor rachel do you think
it's expected that um almost half
think chancellor wishy sunak would do a
better job and take more seats at the
next election
i think it's a really interesting uh
poll as you say and i think actually
rishi sunuk is someone who
particularly towards the beginning of
the pandemic was very much in the public
light he was bringing forward furlough
he was getting a lot of praise from a
lot of different people about how he was
specifically handling the pandemic
and his public appearances seemed to to
go up you know and the number of people
who who know him and the support that he
gave through that and so i don't think
as is just being said i think you know
we are
midway through the parliamentary term it
is no good shock given what has happened
over the past couple of years
specifically what's happened in the last
couple of months actually that toy
members might be looking around
questioning whether boris johnson is the
right person to lead them into another
election and we know that the
conservatives can be pretty brutal when
it comes to winning they are a party
that likes to win and they like to have
someone in place they know can win and i
think that is what we'll be um
they will be looking at as we go into
the council elections that i mentioned
earlier when we get to that point when
we see how the conservatives do across
the country they might start looking
around seriously then and thinking you
know who is this is boris johnson is his
political capital enough for us anymore
what promises has has he broken and is
he still a winner rachel and jasmine
thank you very much for taking us
through the papers this hour